it's seven o'clock 9 p.m here in Kiev
and this is a Sky News special marking a
year of conflict in Ukraine
a country counting the cost of Russia's
illegal Invasion after Putin's attempted
Blitzkrieg and hope of a swift Victory
were thwarted
Maneuvers in New York will see the testy
exchange between Ukraine and Russia at
today's un security council meeting
and we'll look at what's next in the war
as the first Western tanks are delivered
by Poland to Ukraine
our correspondence will be live for us
here in Russia in New York and Berlin
thousands of civilians killed tens of
thousands of soldiers and millions still
displaced the war in Ukraine one year on
British Sheldon is very close
the wreckage of Russian Vehicles is
littering this street it's full of sweet
oh
there we go it started before Dawn
can you hear that Mark
[Music]
and this would test even the fit and
healthy but those still fleeing are the
most vulnerable the elderly the frail
and the very young there's no water no
electricity they're still hanging on I
don't know how they're doing it but they
are they are going west to safety he
will now Head East to fight there is
going to be one Almighty Crush as people
try to get on
rods going on behind you now
whatever fell from the sky made a crater
this big
[Music]
Crawford from Sky News clawed the sky
and stop bombing don't don't speak about
the bureaucratic steps
it's a professional Ambush the bullets
just don't miss
the five of us have made it out of the
car down the embankment and we just
can't believe we're alive
good evening from the Ukrainian Capital
key
we want to see what's left of the
missile here the words on the side of
that zadeti it means four children the
train station was packed with people
trying to find a way out this is what
it's like in
custard
a mass grave here triggered Global
horror
these boys are out every day protecting
their Village but what's left of it with
their own checkpoint and toy guns
at first we were scared really scared
but now we are ready to fight
fights like hell
through here the
making the molotov cocktails
Vladimir Putin thought that Russian
forces would capture key within days
they failed
instead his forces are bogged down in a
war
that they're unwilling to leave and so
far incapable of winning this is
absolutely incredible we're on the
outskirts of Kirsten now we've been
given a military escort
and as you can see people are absolutely
beautiful
finally leopard two tanks are coming
from Europe you must be relieved
uh
[Music]
um
in war it is always the children
always the children displaced
always the children without a say in
what adults are doing to their world
foreign
for a year now War has raged in Europe I
thought unimaginable to many even days
before The Invasion the consequences
have been felt around the world and
pushed the West to unite in a way they
failed to after Putin's invasion of
Crimea but as this conflict moves into a
war of attrition some fear this may not
be the last anniversary we see today
though president zielinski told his
people they had shown themselves to be
invincible
tonight we'll report from here in Kiev
where I'm joined by our defense and
security editor Deborah Haynes our
correspondent Alex Rossi is on the front
line in eastern Ukraine looking at the
toll this war is taking we'll get the
view from Russia's home front a year
into the war with our correspondent
Diana magnet in eastern Siberia and in
the United States Mark Stone will give
us an update on the global diplomatic
wranglings to keep her support for
Ukraine shored up
but first this evening Deborah Haynes
looks now at the war in Ukraine one year
on
commemoration
Ukraine marks one year of War by
honoring those who died to keep this
country free
the president Russia wanted to topple
the still in charge
foreign
hurting
but defiant
[Music]
in the town of butcher where a mass
grave was found the pain runs deep
Russia's brief occupation here has left
permanent scars
foreign
this memorial wall in Kiev is a reminder
that Ukraine has actually been under
attack since 2014.
that's when Russia first invaded and
annexed Crimea
it became a frozen Conflict at times all
but forgotten by many in the West
Vladimir Putin changed all that last
year galvanizing allies in a way that
hasn't been seen since the Cold War but
Russia isn't backing down and neither is
Ukraine
despite the security risk the president
gave a live press conference in a sign
of growing confidence
you believe that Ukraine can achieve
Victory on the battlefield or do you
believe that ultimately you're going to
have to negotiate maybe even compromise
maybe even talk to Vladimir Putin
businesses
foreign
the war will go on
each flag here in the capital is planted
in memory of the Fallen
a growing Garden of grief and sacrifice
and Deborah is here with me now in that
news conference by president zelinski
was very interesting and it went on a
long time several hours and what did you
make of his tone
his tone was confident it was of a
leader he's he's defied the odds he's
still in power and it's such a contrast
to the first big press conference that
he gave back in April do you remember it
was in the underground in Kiev and we
were all waiting again similar huge
numbers of journalists him Fielding for
hours question after question but at
that time there was there was still
Security today but there was massive
security around that event nothing was
broadcast live and yet this one was live
it was the president in his Capital
still in power a year on from The
Invasion that Vladimir Putin launched
and thought would topple him from that
post within a few days so defiant strong
very much aware that he's still got a
fight on his hand absolutely unwavering
when it comes to the idea of compromise
and saying that they are going to win
and hoping Victory comes this year okay
Deborah thanks very much we'll talk to
you again a little later in the program
and Vladimir Putin's plans for a swift
Victory and a blitzkrieg Rush on Keith
was soon thwarted of course by Ukraine
resistance slowed Russia's progress and
days turned into weeks and then months
and now a year Professor Michael Clarke
has this analysis of the course of the
conflict
if we think about the war on the 24th of
March after about a month it was clear
that the Russians were in several areas
around Kiev in the Northeast in the
donbass and in this land bridge to the
South were four big fronts and although
we could see that the Russians were
making hard work of it we thought that
they will learn they'll get better at it
they made no more hard work of it than
in the great Convoy that was approaching
Kiev from the West we now know it wasn't
a convoy it was a Monumental traffic jam
ten different Battalion tactical groups
all sought the same road to get away
from the soft ground without proper
planning proper communication and in the
end a thousand tanks 2 400 armored
vehicles 10 000 troops were involved in
a 35-mile traffic jam that spent a month
before it could unwind itself that was
Monumental but that's where the war
seemed to be after a month we thought
they'll get it right they'll move in on
these areas and try probably to move
into the area east of the Nipper River
and take the whole of this eastern part
of the country but that's what where we
are today just look at the difference
the red areas indicate where the
Russians occupy the yellow areas of the
two fairly big areas that the ukrainians
have liberated so can't give oblast
khaki region they've got right through
to the border of luhansk and in the west
they've taken back a lot of the cursing
oblasts right through to taking the city
of Kirsten itself making the Russians
abandon the city and so here are the
Russians occupying the donbass which
they now say is their prime target and
holding on to this land bridge very
important to them to maintain control of
Crimea but both sides are now preparing
their offensives as the winter plays
itself out we are expecting a lot more
maneuver on this map and we'll see in
the months to come as the winter Fades
away who has the momentum in the next
phase of this war which certainly will
run through for I guess the better part
of this year at least
Michael Clark there well after the full
scale Invasion president zielinski
rejected a U.S offer to evacuate the
country I need ammo not a ride he
famously said he then turned to
ukrainians calling on them to take up
arms and defend their Homeland a year
into the war and Western estimates put
Ukraine's war dead at around a hundred
thousand now military cemeteries are
constantly Excavating fresh plots to
accommodate those killed in battle our
correspondent Alex Rossi is in the east
of the country for us looking at the
sacrifices being made on the front line
in a Windswept graveyard Victoria Mourns
her husband
you are my life you're my heart my Heir
I love you she says
Ruslan was killed a few days ago when he
was hit by a tank round
his three-year-old twins still don't
understand their father is never coming
home
[Music]
um
telephone
Ukraine does not disclose figures for
its dead but it is a number that's
Rising fast
and so too is the rate of casualties
at this Rehabilitation Center soldiers
try to overcome their injuries
Oleg was lacerated by shrapnel and
doctors have warned him he may still
lose his limb
but despite his sacrifice he says
Russian aggression has only made this
nation stronger
foreign
Putin thoughts would be a lightning
Conquest has morphed into an exhausting
Jewel of artillery
with no end in sight
we're fighting here in the donbass over
the last year has been absolutely
Relentless and it appears to be getting
worse in the face of a new Russian
offensive now in places like this
most people have left
and it's easy to understand why every
day now
the artillery is getting closer
in the shattered broken communities of
this region people are weary
shuffling through the cold to fetch Aid
Parcels as the fighting rages around
them the anointing is
but after a long year the cost of this
punishing war is increasingly only
measured in pain and suffering
and at the cemetery new plots are being
excavated for soldiers that have not yet
been killed in combat
it is a bleak picture and this of course
is just one military cemetery in a
country which is bleeding for its
survival
Alex Rossi Sky News in the donbass
well in Russia the cost of the war is
also clear a mountainous Russian
Republic in eastern Siberia is among the
regions which have suffered the most
casualties among soldiers sent to fight
our Moscow correspondent Diana magnney
traveled to bariatia in Siberia and has
the latest on Russia's home front
feels like it's a world away from war in
Europe it is a different Russia more
like Mongolia next door than Moscow
but drive a little way from the main
city of ulanude and you reach this
graveyard where the true cost of the war
is spelled out in funeral garlands and
Military flags and in the faces of men
all killed six time zones away in
Ukraine
blood is love cook Gordon
he was 20 years old and he died on the
second day of the war on the 25th
of February
Russia's been so reluctant to talk about
their casualties and you don't see these
kinds of scenes on Russian State TV
but they're
have been so many kills
already in this one year of fighting and
it doesn't look like it's going to end
anytime soon
though the numbers are hard to verify
briatia has one of the highest casualty
counts of any Russian region
not her real name has two nephews
fighting in Ukraine both try to
terminate their contracts she says and
they were turned down
um
do you feel that buratians have been
unfairly targeted to fight in this war
um
living standards are low here
unemployment is high an army contract is
Big Money
and nearly everyone has lost someone
foreign
used to attend the rally she could
against War then mobilization till they
were shut down 20
000 people detained in this one year of
War
why did you decide to speak out now
because this is dangerous for you
again
sometimes there are no answers just what
tomorrow brings another day in the
shadow of one man's War
and Diana joins me now from Moscow and
we've seen events of commemoration
across Europe certainly uh across
Ukraine how has this day been marked in
Moscow
it's not being marked to Mark at all in
any kind of official capacity in fact
this is the second day of a four day
holiday and I think a lot of people are
just trying to forget about the war
yesterday was the defender of the
Fatherland day where President Putin
gave a speech and that was the Patriotic
moment that this time last year the
following morning he chose to use to
launch his special military operation as
he called it but at that point he
thought that it would just be a matter
of weeks that it would all work very
fast all the way through this week he
has been giving speeches his
long-awaited state of the nation address
where he's essentially clearly
reconciled himself and had to reconcile
the Russian people to the fact that this
war is for the Long Haul he said it was
the responsibility of Russians
essentially to gather together to
weather this storm and to let them know
that this is going to be economically
extremely costly and of course as you
saw in that report in terms of loss of
life also extremely costly even though
the Russian people are not told the true
cost of of this war and they are not
told the actual numbers we have had some
comments from the Russian foreign
minister today Monastery sorry the
Russian foreign Ministry today in
relation to this uh peace plan that the
Chinese are putting forward Russia as it
has done for a while says that it
welcomes the opportunity to solve the
goals of the special military operation
politically and diplomatically
um but that it will not withdraw troops
from those new territories that it
claims as its own and that any peace
negotiations would have to take into
account these new so-called territorial
realities well you can be pretty sure
that Ukraine is not going to take them
into account all the rest of uh most of
the rest of the world and in fact
looking at that General Assembly
resolution yesterday calling for a just
peace in Ukraine at the foreign Ministry
also said rather predictably that of
course the result where uh seven people
only seven countries is only voted
against the resolution was because the
rest had been bullied and blackmailed by
the U.S and the west
and threatened with sanctions to cast
their vote in the West's favor it's
pretty typical to hear this kind of
commentary from the foreign Ministry but
it does suggest that the likelihood of
any kind of peace talks anytime soon is
really extremely remote
Diana thank you very much indeed and
we're going to get more on that now
because top diplomats have been
gathering in New York uh today for the
meeting of the U.N security Council the
talks centering around the anniversary
of the war with those testy exchanges
between the Russian and Ukrainian
members during Council the ukrainians
foreign minister called for a minute
silence but even during that solemn
session came a rather disdainful
Interruption by the Russian
representative from New York our
correspondent Mark Stone looks now at
that moment and examines the world view
of this war a world far from United
Security Council is called to order
in the security Council chamber
Ukraine's foreign minister wanted to
remember the cost of the past year the
cost of Russia's invasion
I kindly ask everyone
to observe a minute of Silence
in memory of the victims of the
aggression but Russia's representative
here interrupted the silence he had
another idea
and that is why we're rising to honor
the memory of them all
the Russian version of history is that
Ukraine started all this the minute
silence resumed he had successfully
seized the moment
they were in this chamber a year ago
exactly when Vladimir Putin in Moscow
chose to announce his move on Ukraine it
represented a total rejection of this
chamber this institution and the global
order it tries to preserve
and this anniversary was a chance to
count the cost
Putin cannot must not win in Ukraine
because what at stake on the
battlefields
is the international order itself
and that is at the heart
of the United Nations
if Russia stops fighting and leaves
Ukraine the war ends
if Ukraine stops fighting Ukraine ends
the fact remains
one man
Vladimir Putin started this war
one man can end it
there is such symbolism to this place
the highest diplomatic body in the world
moments in here have changed history and
yet right now it does feel powerless
never mind the overwhelming rejection of
Russia and its actions in Thursday's
vote here Russia has a seat and the
power to block any initiatives that are
proposed the Chinese did present one a
12-point plan hardly a road map to peace
but an indication that they haven't
moved even closer to Russia first of all
I would like to thank you in your
Nations as the Western Alliance foreign
ministers spoke their leaders gathered
for a meeting of the G7 the outcome
bluntly was more words but nothing to
unlock a negotiation the message the
fighting cannot stop until Russia
withdraws
back in New York the shuttle diplomacy
for what it's worth continues in truth
though this day could only be about
reflection of a year that changed the
world because there is no projection for
what comes next we never give up we are
ukrainians thank you
foreign
session and one that well resolves not
very much
yeah once again the United Nations
proves to be such a powerful institution
in terms of the words it's able to
project and in this case the unity
against Russia but beyond that the teeth
are not at all sharp look Mark I think
over the course of the past year
diplomats on all sides here in New York
have wondered many times uh Gravely
Gravely wondered where this conflict
could go the fact that talk of of
nuclear weapons attacked talk of World
War III has not materialized is
Testament I think to the very very
careful diplomacy that we have seen here
in New York and in capitals around the
world but it is also a reflection of
bluff and Bluster on behalf of Vladimir
Putin but nevertheless the concern that
such an unpredictable man with nuclear
weapons in Russia could do something it
is always there and I think that is why
it's careful careful careful approach
all always here in Washington in New
York the words have been very strong
today the actions well there's very
little they can do
okay mark thank you very much indeed
this is a Sky News special from Kiev
coming up
one of Ukraine's staunchest allies since
the start of the invasion we'll see how
the UK pay tribute to those killed in
the conflict and get the latest from
Germany a country that could prove
crucial for a Ukrainian victory
[Music]
let's get more now on the Diplomatic
push to support Ukraine let's speak to
Michael Carpenter the United States
ambassador to the organization for
security and cooperation in Europe thank
you very much for being with us and I
just wonder first of all a year on
whether you can
actually believe that this is going on
in Europe in the 21st century and so
much damage is being done to
infrastructure and so much damage is
being done to people's lives
yeah Mark well you know we knew before
this War Began we had the intelligence
and the information that the Russians
were planning this of course they had
deployed all that combat force on
Ukraine's borders so we knew it was
coming but that did not stop us from
being so shocking in terms of not just
the scale and scope of the war but the
atrocities that Russian forces are
committing I mean we're talking about
crimes against humanity we're talking
about filtration camps in the 21st
century and kids being deported against
their will torn from their families in
Ukraine and sent to essentially be
rucified and re-educated in Russia it's
something that to be honest with you I
never thought I'd see in my lifetime not
on this scale
and Michael the other shocking thing is
that there is no end in sight
no that's right I mean this continues to
be a battle of attrition on the
battlefield
however I do think that Ukraine will
prevail in this War I can't tell you
when but it's clear that ukrainians are
defending their homes and their families
and their neighborhoods and so they've
got the moral Authority and they've got
the the willpower and the determination
on their side
the Russian troops are demoralized
they're poorly LED uh they don't really
know what they're fighting for I mean
this claim that they're trying to
denoxify Ukraine is patently ridiculous
um and so I think Ukraine has the
advantage in terms of willpower but it's
going to be ultimately a matter of
whether the West can provide them with
the weapons and equipment that they need
to sustain the advantage over the long
term
yeah well that is the point do you think
Western Unity will be maintained as you
know this second year progresses
I do you know it's remarkable how many
times pundits and others in the media
have predicted the Western Unity was on
the verge of crumbling over the course
of these last 365 days and yet we've
held together you know we've stood tall
we've stood with Ukraine and we've
continued to accelerate the types of
equipment uh and the capabilities that
we've been able to provide to Ukraine I
mean don't forget at the beginning of
this war Javelin missiles were
considered something that was a taboo
that had been just broken and that was
an exceptional piece of equipment to be
providing to Ukraine now we're talking
about main battle tanks and potentially
other types of uh capabilities like uh
fighter jets that no one thought we
would be discussing a year ago
and what about your organization the RSE
what can your organization do to reduce
tensions here presumably given you know
what is happening not not much
well uh look I'll be honest with you
Mark I don't see much scope for dialogue
here at the osc the Russians come to the
table every week spewing their
disinformation lies and propaganda so
there's no real genuine dialogue where
we can exchange ideas about how to get
to a peaceful resolution to this war
um however what we are doing at the osc
we've we've had a conceptual Innovation
here everything we've done for the last
30 years has been based on consensus and
just in the last four or five months
we've deployed a field operation to
Ukraine that is the first osce field
Mission ever to be deployed abroad that
is non-consensual in nature that is
essentially funded just by like-minded
States uh including the United States
which has made a generous contribution
and many of our allies as well and that
field Mission will focus on Ukraine's
wartime needs things like d mining
things like psychosocial support for war
affected populations mitigating the
tremendous environmental disaster that
Russia's war is causing in Ukraine and
things of that nature so
um you know we are making uh an impact
albeit maybe not as large as I'd like to
see on the ground but we need to
continue to ramp up our efforts
and finally and briefly I mean what do
you think the consequences of failure
here are failure
um to uh you know help Ukraine win this
well look the consequences are enormous
the ramifications could not be any
bigger uh we're not just talking about
one country attacking another over
disputed territory and we're not even
just talking about a violation of the
fundamental rules of the international
order like sovereignty and territorial
Integrity we're talking about a country
a nuclear power a permanent member of
the U.N security Council invading its
neighbor for no reason whatsoever and
then perpetrating the most horrific and
inhuman crimes uh on the ground as part
of its campaign to intimidate the
population in Ukraine and frankly to
wipe the Ukrainian nation-state off the
map of Europe if we allow this to stand
then I don't you know I fear the type of
world that our kids and grandkids will
live in it will not be the sort of place
that we want uh and so we really have to
put an ends to this naked aggression and
all of its various ramifications which
are just horrific and no one should want
us half stand
okay Ambassador appreciate your time
thank you for coming on the program
thank you
now from the moment of the invasion the
United Kingdom positioned itself as one
of Ukraine's staunchiest allies whether
providing homes for Ukrainian refugees
sending Aid to those who stayed behind
or leading the push to supply Ukraine
with ever more powerful weapons today
that solidarity was on full show as the
anniversary of the war was marked
inzaman Rasheed has been looking at how
the United Kingdom is paying tribute to
those lost in the conflict
[Music]
it's 11 o'clock a minute silence
not for Wars gone by
but for a war of our time
it was less remembrance more solidarity
for a country that's faced a year of
brutal aggression
Prime Ministers passed
and present
paid their respects as ukrainians who
now call Britain home prayed for an end
to this conflict
in the city of Bradford we met Olga
forced to leave her family and friends
she's now been living here for eight
months for many like her it's been a
year of pain it was a year of lost it
was a year when you lost your home your
friends your life
and all of us tried to find another
another place to live another friends
and other people who can support us so
it's one year of our fight
giving up simply isn't an option for the
Ukrainian Community with a deep history
in Bradford here hope and strength over
the last 12 months has been needed more
than ever
these are Yana's most recent memories of
Ukraine as she fled with her family
bombed buildings on their route out
there's no clearer reminder of War one
half of your mind living in Ukraine
every day she's been here now since
August last year she wants nothing less
than to return home one day you just
like this
you didn't preparate yourself to all
this and when you when you're going you
don't know where to go and you don't
know what what's waiting you next day
and where you will be next day
and how you will survive this day give
them courage and resilience in battle
to make that happen Ukraine needs help
something Britain has been providing
since day one of this war today military
recruits receive training in the
Southeast even on this commemorative day
perhaps a sign there may be more
anniversaries to come into membership
Sky News Bradford
well potentially crucial to any
Ukrainian Victory would be the fulsome
support of Europe's biggest economy
Germany where other NATO countries like
the US Poland and the UK have led on
supplying weapons Germany has proved
much more reluctant the country dealing
with its own past Germans lean towards a
more pacifist foreign policy but that
opinion may be shifting let's speak to
uh Europe correspondent Siobhan Robbins
who is in Berlin so Siobhan
um what are the German people making of
all this what is their attitude to
supporting Ukraine actively
well if you have a look behind me you
can see the Brandenburg gate lit up in
the colors of Ukraine I think that shows
you what Germany thinks as a whole
there's a huge amount of support for
ukrainians hundreds of people here today
took to the streets to show their
support erect Russian tank was parked
outside the Russian Embassy here people
really back the ukrainians and we've
seen the war triggering huge changes
here in the last year and historic
turning point in military investment for
example a breakaway from Russian energy
a million Ukrainian refugees welcome but
as you say there have also been some
challenges for Germans so we saw a lot
of wrangling before finally the go-ahead
was given for the leopard two tanks to
go some of which have arrived today and
also the history of Germany continues to
weigh heavy over public opinion real
concern here about escalation so for
example a recent poll about sending s16
Jets only 25 percent of people support
that and I think the next 12 months will
bring more challenges as Germany tries
to continue to support Ukraine Ukraine
asks for more and more weapons and
Germany has to Wrangle with its own red
lines
Siobhan thank you very much indeed let's
have a look at China's role in all this
now and Beijing has been calling for a
comprehensive ceasefire saying it wants
to prevent the Russia Ukraine crisis
from getting out of control over the
last year Beijing has been providing
Russia with support but the U.S believes
it may be preparing to ramp up that
support and to sell it weapons our Asia
correspondent Helen Ann Smith has this
report
[Music]
displays of prowess is something China
is good at the West once hoped this
power could be the broker of peace
but it has spent the last year quietly
providing Russia with Finance technology
and diplomatic cover the Americans now
believe it's also preparing to sell arms
China's position ultimately boils down
to a pretty cynical calculation about
what is best for China it does care
about its International reputation but a
relationship with a strong Russia also
provides Commodities a peaceful northern
border and crucially a like-minded Ally
in an increasingly tense standoff with
the West
and it shifts in that standoff that may
be pushing China closer to Putin
that's my Air Force right there buddy a
row over a spy balloon just the latest
low ebb
in fact China's top Diplomat went to
Moscow this week solidifying what the
two leaders once called a No Limits
friendship
but there is caution too Victor Gower
spent his career amongst the top
echelons of China's leadership and just
listened to how he couches the terms of
that friendship Without Limits doesn't
mean that there should be no bottom line
there still should be a border line to
your friendship which does not have an
upper seating to it and what should be
the bottom line that is U.N Charter
respecting each other sovereignty and
territorial integrity and whatever
problems or disputes there are you need
to resolve them by peaceful means
reporting of the war is highly sanitized
here America and NATO framed as the
aggressors a useful narrative if China
ever made its own move on Taiwan what it
does next will be watched intently it
could well alter the course of this war
Helena Smith's Sky News in Beijing
foreign this is a Sky News special live
from Key this evening coming up with
Ukraine accusing Russia of potentially
70 000 war crimes we return to Butcher
and hear the story of one woman who
watched her mother watched as her mother
was shot
[Music]
now Ukrainian authorities say they are
investigating almost 70 000 war crimes
committed by Russian forces but that
Justice won't be easy we've been
following the heartbreaking case of one
21 year old woman who saw her mother
shot dead as they walked home in butcher
earlier I traveled back to that town
where evidence of Russia's war crimes
shocked the world
it happens somewhere here in the forest
on the outskirts of butcher tetiana
sichkar is telling me how a war crime
has devastated her life suddenly I heard
a very loud gunshot so something maybe
it was blood or maybe it was a bullet
she shows me a picture of her and her
mum the most important woman in her life
and she explains what happened the day
they tried to walk home as Russian
troops occupied their streets and the
Woodland tracks nearby and that shot
rang out
I screamed lay down
and we all fall on the ground
I tried to shake her her leg she didn't
answer her head was all in blood there
was blood everywhere
uh her eyes were still open and she was
just staring and I started to scream I
screamed for maybe five minutes where do
you think the shot came from
fazer believed it because the Russians
were
there
the sniper was
on the second floor of that white
building behind the trees
Tatiana leads us to the grave of her
mother here it is
of course I miss most of her because she
was the closest one to me
but
yeah the life's hard yeah but it's hard
but it's go goes on
do you think
you will see the person who did this in
a court of law on trial
it's very likely that that person is
already dead but if that person is still
alive
I believe that I will see him in the
courts and he'll take all the
responsibilities and
maybe I'll ask him what makes him do it
to my family
so now she is pursuing Justice regular
meetings with human rights lawyer Oksana
mikhailovich they want Ukrainian police
to Stage a reconstruction next month to
at least establish exactly where the
shot came from so they can perhaps
identify the Russian military unit
involved they will then go after the
commanders
I am sure there should be responsibility
for each crime says Oksana I will not
stop because it is important Tatiana
says she owes it to her family to fight
she will not give up
one grave site one war crime one
destroyed life among so so many here
and we will follow Tatiana's story
Deborah is back with me now for a final
thought we were here a year ago we're
here now do you think we'll be here in a
year's time
the fundamental problem is that nobody
knows there is no unified
idea about what the solution to this war
is for Vladimir Putin he's going to keep
on fighting he's showed no sign of
wanting to back down and for Ukraine
this is fundamental they say that they
rightly want to regain their territory
as of the 1991 borders which means all
Russian forces out not just from the
donbass but also from Crimea and so as
long as you have those two totally
polarized views on what the outcome
might be the war will continue I mean
fundamental for Ukraine the question is
I guess is it fundamental for the West
for other European countries for the
United States because they are going to
provide the wherewithal for them to to
win this war
if you take them at their word which is
all we can do then it's absolutely
fundamental to the entire foundation of
the world order that has been built up
since the end of the second world war
that's what we're talking about here is
about respecting the the UN Charter
respecting the right of sovereignty
respecting Sovereign borders the prime
minister of Ukraine who I spoke to
yesterday said to me that if it can be
allowed to stand that in this day and
age a country's border can be violated
and there is no consequence there is no
pushback then that means the lesson to
other authoritarian regimes is that
thing that can happen again and that can
only lead to one thing and that is war
war potentially even the third world war
yeah and look 15 seconds you were with
president zielinski today what was his
mood what was his tone
confident confident he was live giving
his press conference he believes he
hopes his country will win and he needs
it to win Deborah thank you very much
indeed and uh in the past year the dec's
Ukraine appeal has raised more than 400
million pounds in the UK we'll leave you
with the voices of ukrainians in their
Homeland
and singing uh They'll Never Walk Alone
when you walk through a storm
hold your head up high
[Music]
at the end of the storm
there is a golden sky
and the sweet silver song
overlock
walk on through the vein walk on through
the rain
for your dreams beetles and blown walk
on walk on this club in your heart and
you'll never walk out